all right yeah so I'm gonna give you a
brief tour off so I could learn today
before I'm gonna do that just a little
bit about myself so I did my PhD and in
computer science actually have a PhD in
computer science without taking any
classes at University in Bonn I did a
brief stint as machine learning at
Amazon and Berlin went to the NYU Center
42 science and I now lecturer at the
Columbia University in the data Science
Institute
so what ass I could learn so I could
learn is a Python library and it's a
Python library for machine learning and
I want to talk today about how this
might be different from what you used to
instead of how machine learning is
viewed in scikit-learn and what are the
main paradigms so ii learned has a lot
of stuff in it it has a bunch of
algorithms so actually like everything
you find it in a centered machine
learning textbook will be implemented
there like classification regression
k-means clustering DB scan whatever
tease me and there's all of these
algorithms together with tools to
evaluate these algorithms and tools to
tune hyper parameter to cross-validation
and these things it's been pretty
successful like here's some logos of
companies that worked with it but
actually I think most companies now that
do machine learning somewhere use it in
some place so it's heavily used industry
and also like a bunch of research so we
nearly have 10,000 research since
thousands attentions on the paper which
would really makes me want to be on the
paper which I'm not so so ii learned is
a really big community effort so this
are like these are the core developers I
think there's about 40 there's about 50
people contributing every month so I'm
not the person who created it that are
some people in the top row but I've been
like one of the core developers for the
last seven years or something like that
so what we're really proud of and second
learn is in particular our documentation
which I you should definitely check out
some people said oh you don't need to
read a machine-learning book you can
just read the documentation I don't
entirely agree with this but I think we
did a pretty good job in particular we
have like
whole bunch of examples so you can go
through and look at the gallery and see
how everything works and I think that's
pretty good
let's I want to talk to you about how
this actually works and how you can use
it in practice so first basic API so
scikit-learn works on numpy array so now
hyeri's are homogeneous arrays so that
means they have one data type so they're
quite different from data frames and so
we assume that our input data is some
float matrix X where like each row
corresponds to one sample and each
column corresponds to one feature or one
independent variable and so this would
be our input and we have a separate
array if we do classification or
regression that is a would be outputs or
labels so we have two different objects
one for data one for a targets and so we
most of the algorithm since I could
learn assume that everything is a float
so by default none of these work with
categorical data or missing values this
is something you have to take care of
yourself I'm gonna talk a little more
about this later but it's a sort of the
basic paradigm and we always call the
data ax and the labels Y alright so
here's how I think about machine
learning pipeline particular supervised
machine learning which is sort of the
most common used form so you start with
this training data and your training
labels and you built a model which could
be like linear regression random force
gradient boosting whatever and you have
some new data for what you don't have
labels usually for which you can want to
make predictions often you want to
evaluate how would your model list so
actually you have hold our test data
with test labels which allows you to say
okay my model generalizes just as well
so for me machine learning means that
I'm mostly interested in how well my
model generalizes I'm like I now hear
people that maybe have more statistics
background where you're more interested
in understanding the model scikit-learn
is really tuned towards making
predictions and making accurate
predictions so I don't think there's
none of the values have and none of the
models have any P values associated with
them and scikit-learn so if you're
looking for that this is not the right
thing if you want to make accurate
predictions then scikit-learn will be
helpful all right so this is sort of the
standard workflow in supervised machine
learning and this is there's basically
two phases you're trying to model but is
your train data and then you want to
generalize to new data and this is
murdered very directly in a second learn
API so all the algorithm since I could
learn are implemented as Python classes
so let's say I want to write enforce
classifier there's a Python class that's
called random force classifier to Train
random forests for classification these
objects contain both the algorithms or
encapsulate the algorithms for building
the models and for making predictions
they will also store all the model
parameters so here for example in the
random force classifier if I call fit
fit we'll build the model and this will
store all the trees all the splits of
the trees and so on in this CLF object
all models in scikit-learn have a fit
function and it always looks exactly the
same way it always gets the training
daytime which i call x train and if it's
a supervised algorithm like here it gets
also the desired outputs y train so this
filter function stores the model and CL
in CLF so this is sort of all you have
to do to build a random forest if you
want to apply this to new data they are
CLF not predict which you input only any
new data that you have or you could also
do the training data and will return the
predictions according to the model
there's also a score function which is
basically just a helper function that
does both the prediction and then Avella
weights again against some known ground
truth so see LF that score makes
predictions on X test according to the
model and then you compare to Y test and
then it reports accuracy so this is sort
of the most common interface first I
could learn and like all the models for
classification regression will follow
exactly as interface and you mostly need
to think about fit and predict these are
sort of the core methods
there's another interface since I could
learn it's also very important in
particular in unsupervised learning and
in pre-processing so this is for
unsupervised learning and/or
pre-processing where someone gives you a
training data set and say you want to do
PCA so you have your training data
there's no labels or grand truce or
something like this you just have your
matrix X and you built a model from this
then when you get some new data or you
have your test data you want to apply
this model and this model will give you
a new view of your data so let's say a
projection onto the principal components
or something like that this is sort of a
slightly different task and has a
slightly different interface so the way
this works since I can learn is again
everything is encapsulated I was an
object so if I have PCA hey I want to do
PCA I instantiate the PCA object I call
fit again all things in scikit-learn
have a fit method and so here I just
give it the training data ax because
it's an unsupervised method and then if
I want to actually project to the
principal components I used to transfer
method on any data this will give me my
new view my new representation of the
data X new so these are basically the
three main functions you need to
understand for scikit-learn is so we
call our models estimator so estimators
could be anything like random forest or
scaling your data or something like this
I'll have a fit method they always take
the data X if it's a supervised method
it also takes some target output Y if
you predict something that is like a
labeling so for classification
regression and clustering you use the
predict method to make this prediction
and if you want to get a new few of the
data a new representation in new acts
you use the transfer method which is
used for pre-processing dimensionality
reduction feature selection and feature
extraction
so these are sort of the two main
building blocks are things to transform
your data and things to make predictions
but we also have more building blocks
for sort of standard machine learning
tasks particular from model evaluation
and selection so there's tools to do
trained has split which is like very
simple I'm not actually going to talk
about this but after instead of doing a
train tests split you want to use
cross-validation I think you're all
familiar with cross-validation something
I can skip this where you put your data
say in five folds and you hold on one
fold and train on the other ones and
this gives you more robust estimate of
deep generalization performance of your
model if you want to do that there's a
method called cross vault score in
scikit-learn and cross wild score
sorry not method a function Cresswell's
two or gets an object data and labels
and you tell us how much cross
validation you want to do by default it
is three fold stratified
cross-validation in here I say I want to
do five fold stratified cross-validation
and so this will return the scores on
the test set or on the holdout set for
each of the iteration so here I get five
scores for the five splits of the data
and then I can compute the mean in
standard deviation or something like
that so this is some like one of the
very commonly used tools another tool
that's probably used even more commonly
is to do a grid search to adjust
parameters because all models have
parameters and you always need to tune
them and is always a bit of a pain and
so the workflow that I usually encourage
people to use might not be either one
that you use but that one that I favor
is you take your data you do a training
and a test split then you do
cross-validation or training data set to
tune parameters and then you do a final
evaluation on your test data this way
you have an unbiased estimate of the
generalization performance by running
your tuned model on a test set if you
just did cross-validation to tune your
parameters then
the estimate of generalization
performance that you would have is too
optimistic
so in this workflow which is a things
are the standard supervised learning
workflow for me it's pretty easy to
implement what ii learn there the main
class here at you need is a great search
CVS a great search t v-- implements
great search was cross validation so if
i want to run this whole process I first
put my training data or my data into a
training test with the trend has split
method then I need to define the
parameters I want to search over so here
SVC is the support vector machine but he
faulted use the RBF kernel there's two
parameters associated with this
regularization parameter C and kernel
bandwidth gamma and so now I specify
grid what values of C and gamma do I
wanna try out and so here I basically
give an exponential range from like 10
to the minus 3 till 10 2 to 2 and for
both C and gamma so this defines my
search space that I want to adjust the
parameters over then to actually do the
search I instantiate an object a new
object with this grid search CV and it
gets the model I want to tune and the
parameter grid I can also specify which
metric to use like I want to use a UC or
accuracy or average precision whatever
you want and how I want to do
cross-validation the cool thing here is
that this grid search CV object returns
this grid object in this grid object
just behaves like all the other models
so this thing that does grid search for
us so has like fit predict score was
exactly the same interface as everything
else only if you call fit now what it
will do is it will run cross-validation
find the best parameter models according
to the cross-validation score according
to metric I give it and then use this
best model and retrain this model on the
whole training set so after it does grid
search it returns the model with the
best parameters and so this allows me
then to make predictions so here you see
again this is very
geared towards making predictions it's
very easy to search parameters and then
make predictions with this model on new
data so this is sort of pretty
convenient I think so
one thing I mentioned is that if I could
learn doesn't really automatically do
any pre-processing and so what one of
the reasons to do this is because you
won't really have control over what is
happening like how do you want to encode
your variables how do you want to
compute data and so on and so more often
than not instead of taking your training
data on your trading labels and built a
model there's a lot of things happening
in between like extracting features from
text data or images or whatever you have
rescaling your data in the way that you
think makes sense for your data set
possibly doing automated feature
selection and so on and then it all goes
into your model very common mistake that
people then make is okay then I'm gonna
do cross validation on the model tune
the parameters of the model and this
gives tells me how what my model will be
however if you do this then you're gonna
actually leak a lot of information in
your previous steps for the cross
validation what you really need to do is
make cross validation the outermost loop
and across the very h2 your whole
processing pipeline from feature
extraction scaling project selection all
the transformation you want to do and
then do cross validation over list
select the best model that the best
parameters and then rebuild your model
to make this very simple second learning
a little thing called pipelines so
pipelines are a way to chain together
transformations I call them here t1 and
t2 think about like imputation and PCA
or scaling and PCA or whatever you want
and the classifier and so similar to
cross validation to words or CV making a
pipeline returns a new object that is
again an estimator has again exactly the
same interface as any of the other
models so this pipe object
just looks like a model again only now
it's a chain of the say two
transformations and a classifier so and
then if I call fit on this model it'll
fit the first transformation transform
using the first transformation fit the
second confirmation transform using the
second transformation and pass the
transform data on to the classifier if I
make prediction a prediction on new data
it'll do exactly the same
transformations it will not refit the
transformations will just transform the
data and make sure basically the test
state that gets exactly the same
treatment as a train data in capsule
writing your whole processing pipeline
like this makes it much more unlikely
that you're leaking information or that
you're doing leaking information from
your test set or that you're doing
different steps on training and test set
because you have encapsulated everything
in a coherent unit we have the cool
thing about using pipelines is well it
saves code and also now you can do cross
validation the way you would want to do
it so for example if I want to scale my
data so the SVM in cycle urn doesn't was
scaling I think by default in Rd Lopez
VM wrapper does like 0 mean unit
variance and so I could learn sort of it
doesn't do that so you have to do it
yourself and or you could say well it
allows me to choose more precisely how I
want to pre-process my data ok so I can
make this pipeline here this would be
scale the data and then 50 SVM so if I
want to do grits or show with this I can
just use this pipeline inside the grits
are CV the only thing I need to adjust
is I need to tell Burt search TV which
does the parameter search which steps
inside the pipeline I need to want to
tune the parameter on and so here and
there's this notation with the double
underscore which basically says under
step that's called SVC tuna parameter C
on a step that's called SVC to
mature gamma and so this allows you to
do quick search and cross validation
over these complex pipelines and the
cool thing about this is that you can
not only say do scaling and then grid
search the parameters of the model but
you can grid search parameters of
everything jointly usually
pre-processing methods like feature
selection also have parameters so for
example here I do feature selection
asking I should use one two three or
four features okay so I can select over
how many features should I still should
I select and the parameter scene gamma
support vector machine together in this
pipeline so it says here I have this
pipeline select a best is select a cask
a best feature according to P values the
asper vector machine and now grid search
the best value for K and select K best
and the best value for scene gamma and
support vector machine and so this
allows me to search all these things
jointly and they're all encapsulated in
this single grid object alright I think
that's all I had today so I know that
was really fast but I got 20 minutes and
so now you have all of second learn
nearly yeah I have this book which you
already saw and you can follow me on
Twitter or something like that
[Applause]
you